we're at a point in society today where
we're in the eyeball economy the
attention economy the more followers and
eyeballs you get the better your brand I
mean we saw what happened with Conor
McGregor and he's a a beast regardless
even if he didn't talk but the fact that
he talks so much is just so Amplified
now you've got like sort of The
Reincarnation uh of McGregor with this
guy right how much of an influence in
like his Split Decision or he actually
won was because he's such a big figure
such a public figure that they they want
someone with that much Pizzazz to
continue winning do you see what
happened with this fight this weekend A
lot of people are saying that he didn't
win yeah but you know it's like if
you're gonna beat a guy who like they
want you they want to kind of be up
there you gotta win convincingly I guess
what are your thoughts on just someone
with this a massive personality and how
they operate today well he needs to keep
on training really freaking hard you
know I I never went
saying things about my opponent because
the more you say that you're going to do
the more pressure you put on yourself
because guess what everything you're
saying they will show that on the big
screen when you come out and you hear
yourself saying oh this guy is nothing
I'm gonna slice him up I'm going to
choke I'm going to do this and now
you're walking through the ring and
you're going like [ __ ] I better do it
you see so you put unnecessary pressure
on your shoulders that's what I always
believe so I I try to stay away from
stare Downs I don't like to look in the
eyes I'm a hot at you know if he tries
to do something I'll go and I get angry
once you lose control you lose the fight
you know you need to control anger you
know you need to be calm at all times I
had this coach and my last fighter came
to me just before the fight I went out
and he took me I said can I talk to you
outside he goes okay sure and he says to
me listen man this guy tries to take
food away from your family I go stop
right there that's what do you mean I
said I don't need the stock he says why
not I said because it makes me angry I
don't want to be angry I want to control
it you know once you make you're angry
instead of hitting like this you're
hitting you're loading up because and
you're telegraphing so you want to be as
calm as possible I think that equally
skilled Fighters the guy with the most
control is always going to win
are there those that do better being
angry are there those that perform
better angry yeah a friendly sales I
made a whole freaking career out of it a
lot of machine learning like you know
but sound perfectly technical not so
much you want to clinch with them do not
clinch with the guy he's Gonna Knock You
Out and everything hits and it might
need to be super technical but he can
aim dude I mean everything lands on the
button so you know and he's super
aggressive he just comes one speed full
speed that's it but a really good fight
I never got this you know in the world
father tutor championships over in
Brazil he got beaten by a boxer this is
all the way back before he became big
and the box was just using angles and
footwork and just pick him apart from
the outside and again nobody saw that
fight why would you roll the dice
against a guy like that you put him
against Michael Chandler both of these
guys are the same now it's literally
whoever gets hit first is going to win
but if you're smart just engage yeah the
same thing you know that's a fighter
always exciting but you know finally I
almost want to say thankfully but that's
a bad thing to say he got knocked out
twice and that made him a better fighter
because then he's always thinking yeah
you see that's and I told him way be uh
way before because he used to fight for
the world series of fighting I was the
commentator for that I said dude stop
that fighting style you know you want to
be able to talk to your kids once you
have kids you know this is it's going to
hurt you eventually yeah but the fans
love it I say they don't care you you
lose three fights and you're nobody
anymore that those fans you're really
fighting for those fans be smart you
know and and then when you got knocked
out suddenly he started listening to
Trevor Whitman his coach was an
incredible coach and and now he became a
better fighter because of it can I give
you a little bit of maybe a different
perspective
this is not my world I'm just I'm posing
devil's advocate here this is not Adam
this is me just sort of what would you
say to somebody that says all right bass
I hear what you're saying be stoic don't
get emotional like don't talk trash what
would you say to the person that was
like well bass that was maybe in your
time in the 90s but today in 2022 it's
all about eyeballs if you look at what
like Jake Paul is doing trolling people
McGregor Patty the Baddie the list goes
on
they might say well it's probably even
more important than ever to run your
mouth and talk smack and be a troll what
would you say to those people I would
say look at pharaoh milliona go right
they have a they have a magazine in
Japan where you have like 40 pictures of
all the same facials expressions and
says fatal happy Pharaoh said fat or
angry fatal you know like he never had
an expression never said anything bad
never did anything but everybody want to
see him fight because he was just that
good you know it's very mysterious to
have a guy with no tattoos no profanity
no nothing who's the perfect guy you
know very nice very respected and then
once in the ring he'll just destroys
people I think that guys like that
will pull a lot of fans to them as well
now a lot of people try that but they're
just not on that level so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]